it took an accident the loss of life and
an act of kindness to bring power to
Umar Falls Village in Northern Senegal
when his son babakar saved a visiting
German family from a fatal car accident
a small donation of solar panels
followed irreversibly changing the
village food no longer goes rotten
false grandchildren can study at night
suddenly European football even
Hollywood shows made their way into his
living room changing The Village's
perspective on the world
this is in the work of the state it's
thanks to my son he maintains the panels
the batteries if we had waited for the
government to bring power to my home I
will still be waiting today and living
in the dark
and yet a short distance away off the
coast are large untapped reserves of
natural gas that could light up the
entire Village but with the signing of
the 2015 Paris agreement most countries
agreed to stop the use of fossil fuels
Senegal's president believes that's
unjust climate Justice he says is the
right to use his country's resources and
burn the polluting fossil fuel in order
to bring power to his people
absolutely
it's not normal or fair to ask countries
of which half the population does not
yet have access to electricity to us as
countries to abandon traditional energy
resources and switch to renewable energy
it's not acceptable
while Senegal continues to mostly rely
on heavy Fuel and diesel-powered plants
it has some of the largest solar farms
in West Africa thanks to German and
French investors
after the 2015 Paris agreement bringing
power to Senegal into other Sun drench
African countries meant investing in
this green energy but since the Russia
Ukraine war it seems that priorities
have shifted both for African and
European countries
Europe can no longer rely on Russian gas
Germany and France are now looking to
Africa including Senegal's gas reserves
to meet their power needs the fear of a
looming energy crisis means some
countries appear to be turning their
back on the Paris agreement now Senegal
is under pressure to provide fossil fuel
energy to Europeans while its people
look towards the Sun for power
Nicholas Hawk Al Jazeera al-nuguran
Northern Senegal